anywhere was named the local hero in the
Australian of the Year awards and he was
listed in the world's top 10 teachers
all of this because he makes maths fun
and interesting and now his latest book
is Wu's wonderful world of maths so
let's welcome back to studio 10 oh one
and only Eddie whoo hey I love that you
enjoy teaching maths but for many of us
it just wasn't our best subject at
school and that's why I'm in television
where do you start well for me I have to
say I identify with that a lot Angela I
had a lot of difficulty with mathematics
at school English history drama there
was sort of things that felt much
natural to me but I realised after
giving this a go and teaching a bin
teacher more ten years now it's
something I think everyone can learn and
that's what I'm here to show you a
little bit of fantastic know you brought
some card I do have a couple of props
here so one of the things we really
think is important is people need to
realise mathematics is all about patents
you know there are lots of patterns in
things you might not necessarily expect
and that includes things like a deck of
cards so I'm just gonna sort of thin
them out just so you can see these are
all different cards here and they've got
some cool little Australian icons on
them these are Qantas cards but they're
all different cards they're not all the
same right now in order to show you a
trick with this I need a bit of your
help so no rather can you give me a
number between 10 and 20 okay out loud
yeah 13 13 okay so I'm going to deal out
13 cards 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13
very good okay now I'm lucky well we'll
see if it's gonna be lucky for us okay
now Peter can I ask you for a number as
well this time can you give me a number
between 7 and 13 any number you like 9 9
ok very good now I'm going to take these
two numbers 13 9 and show you a really
beautiful pattern but before I do that
these cards I'll make sure they're all
really mixed up ok so I'm going to
shuffle them through there I'm gonna do
a bit of a arm a cut here like so and in
the last one the fanciest one is the
what they call the riffle shuffle so it
looks like this you sort of put them
together like that and you sort of sorry
make sure I do this right I like so if
you're coordinated and then it all comes
together okay now pick your number was
nine one okay
here we go so one two three four five
six seven eight nine put them on top
done it once one two three four five six
seven eight nine put them on top one
last time one two three four five six
seven eight nine put it on top now
nirodha you really chose those numbers
didn't you I didn't I should do that
your free choice okay it was all mixed
up or shuffled but I reckon using
mathematics there's a pattern here that
can help me predict what this card is on
the top I think it's the ten of diamonds
do you want to see if that's right the
ten Oh diamonds my friends this is great
quote I love which is that um things are
magic until you understand them do you
want to see how this okay so here's I'm
gonna do I've got this little space here
to write on and I'm going to illustrate
what's going on tell me this doesn't
turn into calculus oh no character
involved it is important to know one of
the things that mathematicians do all
the time when a problem looks really
strange and complicated and big we look
at a simpler version of the problem and
I'm gonna show you a simpler version
here it's a little easier to write and
then we see if that principle will help
us understand okay so use what I'm gonna
do instead of a big number like say 13 I
don't pick a smaller number like say six
will do okay so if I had six cards let's
number them so one two three four five
and now this sixth one down here I'm
gonna put a different color on it and
you'll see why in a second I'm gonna
call it via the X card okay it's very
important to me you'll see why in a
second now we had those cards in my hand
and then I dealt them out now how did I
deal them well I asked you for a
different number right you said nine in
this case I'm gonna go with four again
just smaller to keep it going now
imagine these are the cards in my hand
as I deal them down what's the first
card that goes down on the table it's
gonna be the one on the top right so
card number one goes closest to the
table let's draw a table here okay
what's the next card that goes down
it'll be two and I keep on going right
three and then four but then I didn't
get all the way through the pack do you
know you only told me to deal out
so I took what was left in my hand I've
dealt one two three four what's left in
my hand now it's a these guys and then I
just put them down on top so now they've
put down on top like this
yes okay so this is what it looks like
now I've done it once is my first time
I'm gonna go again right but watch what
happens what's the first card fine it's
a five right it's the five it's the X
and then it's the four yeah I got so
much audience participation here then
the three and then lastly I put down
these last two and then one but the
other way around okay I did it
sometimes you see what's going here's
the last time careful viewers would have
noticed I did this exactly three times
watch what happens I'm gonna start
dealing down what's the first card that
goes on the table it's the tooth yep
then one then 33 then the four and then
I take these guys and I whack him on the
top yes that's that special card I told
you about and lastly this guy and then I
reveal oh I know what this card is
because I sort of snuck a quick look at
the bottom and I knew that this pattern
would emerge you can see how this card
moves around and it always you do it
nope you see they give a question to you
please please I have a question if I'd
have said eight would you still do it
three times a fight absurd that's right
in fact you see instead of doing 13 and
9 I did 6 and 4 here I could have done
50 and 30 it will always work are you
allowed into casinos yeah they've got my
face on posters now and they say do not
allow entry but there's the pattern the
basis for a lot of magic tricks a lot of
magic tricks are actually just and now
you understand this that's awesome
yeah and just grift kids at schools look
I would never encourage you to do that
but you totally could
now why okay short now we all have a few
loops of paper actually because one of
the things which I talk about in my book
is that people often think math is all
about numbers and clearly there are some
numbers involved
right but Matt's is more than numbers
and that's why I've got these little
props here oh I've lost one there was a
green one that's just disappeared it's
uh yeah I want to show you there's a P
so much rather trained professional
would know that these pieces of
cardboard here nothing to do with
numbers and you can see all I've done is
I've taken through cardboard and I've
stuck it together so you got a bit of a
loop so the camera can see down there
okay now I'm gonna do something really
obvious you can think what's the big
deal here I'm gonna cut this loop in
half okay now you can see it's sort of
like a cylinder and as I cut it in half
no surprises when you cut an object like
this in half well when you finish going
all the way down unsurprisingly you get
amazing now Narada you also have a loop
here yes I wonder if you could take your
pair of scissors okay and before you as
you get ready to cut it yeah what you
can see is the Otters loop is a little
bit different to mine it's not twisted
around a little bit I'm cutting it okay
yeah go ahead
down the middle now there's a sort of
turn in this twist and as you can see
they're out a cutting about she's doing
exactly the same thing that I was doing
it's exactly the same kind of cardboard
that I had just a different color but as
you get toward the end just slow down a
little bit okay
before everyone sees what happens what
do you predict will happen okay now did
you want to fish the car yes we're gonna
be separate surely okay now once there's
cut it would you hold that up for us
please what's going on there this is
this is not two pieces okay this is one
okay yeah he is the last fun bit okay do
you also have a piece of car there it's
a little more twisted okay like what
happens when you do the cut on yours
because you know mine turned into to
yours turned into one and rail died
what's gonna what's gonna happen with
Peters you're right there
they're really ready you're gonna try to
reboot here it is
hold on feed what do you got if you got
one or two go to but they join oh you've
got two separate pieces but if you hold
them up here I'll tape it there we go
this round for you they're joined
together and you see mathematics is
about exploring weird planet geometry
like this it's just a bit of fun it's
Jesus that's what the book is about
Eddie
we love you you are so rock star and so
Eddie's new book it's called Wu's
wonderful world of maths don't forget to
grab yourself a coffee thank you so much
[Applause]